hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are back at the 1911
international tournament of san
sebastian and it's josé raúl capablanca
versus a rudolf Spielman now before we
get into the game and talk a bit more
about this rule of Spielman gentlemen I
would just like to mention that I photos
who who are interested in acquiring more
vast knowledge as in the previous video
capablanca did face carl schlechte and
we also mentioned the 1910 World Chess
Championship match between Hollister and
Emmanuel asker Andrei terekhov feedom
Esther from Singapore Maeda
made an article about the match between
the two of them for chess calm so I will
put a link to it in the description
below it's quite extensive he says that
it took him well I believe he said a few
months but I could be mistaken maybe he
said like two months or something but
it's quite extensive and well if you
wanted you know to check it out I'm sure
you'll enjoy it
and a lot of you have been asking me in
the comments that I should be showing
the finals the standings after each
round of the 1911 son Sebastian
tournament but there is no such thing
available anywhere but I did check for
this round and I did prepare for a few
of them so after 11 rounds Capablanca is
first he's eight and a half out of 12
out of 11 so he's at one point ahead of
everyone else those who are close to him
are Akiba Rubinstein with seven points
Robuchon so far hasn't lost a single
game but he had a bit few more three
more draws than capablanca then dr.
Mullen Vidmar with seven and a half and
Frank James Marshall would also seven
and a half
and so basically capablanca is a full
point ahead of everyone else here he
faces the rudolf Willman some of you
know him from his brutal game says he is
the master of sacrifice even wrote a
book the art of sacrifice in chess and
he was something like in those days he
was something like rashidun is made you
know in his era and he didn't win all
the he won a lot of tournaments but
sometimes he would like win five games
and lose 12 games in
tournament but those five games that he
won were so impressive that everyone
talked only about those games and he
also has a very impressive score about
against Capablanca but we are going to
talk about that after this game so
Capablanca has the white pieces a full
point ahead of everyone else in this
tournament and he opens with v4 we have
d5 Knight to f3 c5 now this early c5 the
cross variation and now c3 in modern
times not a move you would you would
consider playing c4 it is a move that
comes to mind but as Capablanca himself
also enjoyed playing the turret events
for example with 693 you could transpose
into the tower defense but maybe because
Capablanca enjoyed playing the tower
defense himself he decided to go for
well a sideline as you all know
capablanca wasn't all that much into
openings either way but okay Knight to
f6 III we have Knight to c6 and now D
captures on c5 here kappa blanka
leaves the center allows the black this
not with e6 but we v allows black this
massive central control for the price of
one pawn as a coupled one guys like that
before defending the pawn it's not it's
not like for example in the Queens
gambit when you when you capture on c4
because this pawn cannot be challenged
that easily for example if you try
something like this you get Queen a4 you
have to defend the night now b5 you
attack the knight Knight has two more c6
and blacks in in big trouble
so after b4 we have Queen to c7
developing and now Bishop to b2
strengthening the d4 pawn we have Bishop
to e6 Knight B to d2 and now Bishop to
e7 Spillman leaves the open option of
castle in both Kings I don't Queen side
we have Bishop to e2 and now he decides
to Castle kingside
would be a bit safer as Capablanca
already has a lot of expansion on the
Queen side we have castles by kappa
blanka as well and now rook 8 d8 we have
Queen to c2 connecting rooks also
developing the Queen and
at some point Capablanca wants to push
efore we have Bishop to g4 our Spielman
anticipates this efore idea and he wants
his bishop to already be on g4
when f5 is pushed we have E for my
Capablanca D captures on e4 Knight
captures Knight captures Queen captures
and now f5 Queen back to c4 with check
King to h8 and now rook a to d1
developing also countering blacks rook
on on d8 and let's see what happens here
so coupling is still up a pawn but black
still has a massive central control he
no longer has a deep one but by playing
the f5 here again controls really a lot
of space
his rooks are placed excellently the
bishop is very strong the knight is also
very nice but capablanca has a well it's
a questionable Bishop on be too if
coupling can play something like Queen
b3 if c4 can come then the bishop comes
alive in the bishop will be an excellent
piece but for now the c3 point is
actually quite useful as it doesn't
allow any night maneuvers for black but
okay we have E for buy black now Knight
has to move Knight to d4 and now of
course Spillman does not want to capture
here if you capture capture then you
fixed a couple blunts pawn structure
after he pushes d5 the bishop comes
alive white will be much better here
so after 94 we have a Knight e5 black
now has a lot of pressure here the Queen
is under attack you have to move Queen
b3 and now Bishop captures on e2 Knight
the e6 is a threat with this powerful
fork so Spillman forces the knight back
we have Bishop captures Knight captures
and now Knight to g4 and already a
couple I don't know if Capablanca was
aware of well if he knew of Rudolph I'm
sure he knew of him he was a he was a
very famous or awful Austrian chess
master but yeah like I said he was very
very known for his sharp play for his
attacks for his winning of not only
tournaments but for plenty of brilliant
prizes in tournaments so he has to be
very careful
the threat is of course Queen captures
on h2
mate how do you defend this you could
block it with g3 but after g3 there are
you're weakening your kingside there are
a lot of moves you have to consider here
now f4 is an idea e3 is an idea the
knight can come to e5 + f3 also a very
strong idea you could decide to go rook
f6 to h6 to put more pressure on h2 so a
lot a lot of attacking possibilities so
Capablanca has to survive this attack
and then he will able to he will be able
to enjoy his extra pawn once he pushes
c4 then his position improves
drastically as this Bishop comes alive
until then he just has to you know
defend and survive
so g3 is a possibility but Capablanca
decides not to do it he goes in Knights
to g3 and he allows black well open
hands now again all of these ideas are
possible rook captures III f4 rook f6 h6
so many ideas here and just to show you
how rich the position is let's see what
happens if something like III is played
then you get pawn captures Knight
captures forking the rooks and now you
have to capture on the 8th route
captures Queen captures and now you have
to play rook to e1 and the game
continues but there are dangers in the
position for example if you try
something like rook f3 attack the knight
then Queen d2 and already black is once
again threatening checkmate and it will
be very hard to get out of this Rock f2
Queen e1 check now you either give up
the rook or you go tonight here and then
Bishop to h4 will win the game for
example g3 Bishop captures you just
capture it H captures as the knight is
pinned and now Knight captures rook
captures and Queen captures and g3 after
the King moves rook f6 to h6 maneuver
will be deadly so a lot of poison to the
position you have to be very careful but
like I said if the rook doesn't wander
off to f3 if rook e1 then white can
still continue playing
but Suleiman goes for f4 and now what do
you do here you could capture on e4 but
then again you have to go you have to
consider if what happens if f3 is played
definitely an unpleasant choice
you go something like night Stewie -
then again f3 it doesn't matter if you
capture on e4 if you just move the night
f3 will be very deadly
for example Knight g3 now f capture son
g2 King captures and now rook captures
on f2 this is deadly because now you
have to capture with the rook and the
rook on d1 will be attacked twice rook
captures 93 Czech picks up the rook King
h1 now you can capture here real
characters you can't recapture with the
Queen tonight also defends the rook now
you have to block not if one now comes
rope captures rook captures Knight
captures and you're up a full piece and
have a very dangerous pass born so here
after this f4 move capablanca decides
the first trade of a pair of rooks with
rook captures rook captures and e8 and
now again you could capture on e4 for
example Knight captures but then again
f3 can be very unpleasant once you move
the knight Knight g3f captures on g2 now
after rook to d1 you can go rook to f8
and again there will be pressure against
the white king kappa blanka decides
against this after rook to d8 Capablanca
ignores his night and plays Queen to
east 6 pressuring the undefended night
on g4 so why not but in doing so he also
has to give up a pawn we have pawn
captures Queen captures on g4 and now G
captures on h2 with check came to h2
looking to h1 only move as the Queen is
also defending this h h2 pawn and now
comes Queen to e5
capablanca now wants to push c4 he wants
to open up this bishop so he would have
also had threats against the black king
and also he's threatening to capture on
e4
so Queen e5 Skillman defends against
both threats but the e d4 pawn is weak
rook to e1 and there is no good way to
defend this pawn here we have rook to d2
now attacking a couple Blancas bishop
here and now kappa blanka simply plays
rook captures on e4 it's a very
important move and it's very important
that the queen is controlling the d1
square so you cannot play rook to d1 if
the Queen wasn't then rob1 would be
as the queen is still guarding the h2
pawn we have Queen back to c7 Spillman
wants to keep control of this diagonal
to be able to have this threat of
checkmate here and here kappa blanka
finds really a brilliant maneuver that
that would just wins him the game
straight out so feel free to pause the
video here and try to take everything
into consideration what what is by
threatening what or blacks auction what
can why - do you know it here kappa
blanka simply uses the entire board to
create this this beautiful maneuver so
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who have watched the video
and have found the idea congratulations
it's it's just a wonderful idea and for
those of you just wanna enjoy the movies
Bishop to c1 not to just save your
bishop as it is attacked but also like
we mentioned the Queen controls d1 so
you cannot do any checkmating here we
have rook captures on f2 now again the
queen is still controlling a ch2 group
to f1 now the threat of checkmate so you
found Bishop to c1 you obviously saw
okay rook captures an f2 what next
now comes the move you if you found then
well you are you are you know you should
be a professional chess player Bishop to
f4 and Bishop to f4
prevents everything and simply attacks
everything
the Queen is no longer controlling the
h2 point so rook to f1 will be nothing
rook to f1 will be simply met with King
captures on h2 and black has nothing his
queen is still under attack another
thing you you're doing is that you're
overloading the Queen the Queen has to
keep an eye on the bishop on e7 the rook
is attacking the bishop on e7 and also
the Queen has to keep an eye on the c8
square black also has back ranked
weaknesses if the Queen wanders off and
doesn't protect the c8 square then Queen
to see it will be checkmate and one last
thing before f4 does it prevents the
rook from reaching f8 which will be
crucial in this attack here we have
Queen to d8 the only square from where
Queen can defend the bishop and the c8
where
but as it often is now the Queen is
overloaded you simply force her to
choose between two squares so what does
kappa blanka play
we have rook captures on e7 and now you
cannot capture the rook if you capture
the rook we already said Queen the c8
will result in checkmate as you've cut
off the ropes control of the f8 square
with this Bishop to f4 move this Bishop
to f4 is is simply amazing you have to
give up the Queen Queen captures this is
checkmate
so after rook captures on e7 a little
filmin tried one other idea we have
Queen to f8 now threatening this double
attack against the bishop but here it's
a winning position for white copper
bunker can win in and a whole lot of
ways but he decides to finish with style
here couple or you can try to pause the
video and try to finish with style
yourself I'll give you a couple of
seconds you know just for you to decide
what to do you could just move the
bishop but that's not finishing with
style for those of you who have finished
with style congratulations you are an
excellent finisher with style if you
played Queen captures on g7 but if you
haven't still I mean you could win in
other different ways this is what
Capablanca played and it was in this
position that Rudolph's Pillman resigned
at the game why did he resign well
there's only one reply here you have to
capture with the Queen and then comes
rook to e8 check you have to block with
the Queen now you can either go Queen to
a fade and rook captures leaves the
white with an extra piece or you can
just congratulate white and say okay
you're the better man play Queen g8 and
allow this very nice checkmate Bishop to
e5 check only move rook f6 and Bishop
captures will be checkmate
but yeah Spillman did not allow this so
even though he was a fierce player he
played a very nice game create a lot of
attacking chances it was in the end
kappa blanka who finished his attack
with a great style which often happens
when you play against a when a strong
position player plays against an
attacker but still I mentioned that we
are going to revisit the remark where I
mentioned that
Rudolph Pearlman is one of the few
players that did not have a negative
score against Capablanca he had an equal
score against Capablanca two wins two
losses and eight draws and yeah not on
not only that but he was he wasn't just
the only player to have do not have a
negative score against capablanca he was
only one of the few players to beat
Capablanca more than once also a great
achievement and he was the only player
who did not did not have a negative
score against kappa blanka and has
beaten capablanca more than once so even
though like I said he he was an attacker
an aggressive player his games often won
brilliance is but due to his style he
very often lost the games due to this
style and this has resulted in him not
winning so many tournaments as he might
have won if he played you know
differently but like Rasheed Nash Medina
and many others who you know employed
this style throughout chess history he
maybe he didn't win so many tournaments
but those games that he won those were
the ones that to watch him that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you are enjoying the coverage of the
capablanca saga so far do check out that
article I mentioned from chess comm so
after 12 rounds Capablanca still in the
lead woods nine and a half out of 12
that's and that's an insane result for
one of the strongest tournaments played
for that time really insane and really
gonna be enjoyable to see how this whole
series turns out but yeah now I would
like to thank Richard Benson peter
macmannus Thomas Gallagher Brian Quran
and in the RICO policy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content thank you all and
have an excellent rest of your day